et sachez que le sidaction avait permis
de recueillir plus de cinq millions et
demi d'euros l'année dernière alors
soutien aux malades aide à la recherche
et à des actions de prévention à quoi
sert précisément
l'argent récolté caroline thébaux
jean-marc notebook c'est la vitrine du
sidaction trois jours de médiatisation 5
millions 700 mille euros récoltés l'an
dernier cette opération coup de poing
représentent un tiers des ressources de
l'association la moitié ce sont les dons
faits toute l'année
viennent enfin financement public et
opérations spéciales comme les soirées
de charité total 18 millions d'euros
récoltés et redistribuer une partie pour
collecter les fonds faire fonctionner
l'association le reste plus des deux
tiers est partie comme ce sens voilà
comment se présente le préservatif
féminin de 50% pour la prévention
notamment chez les jeunes et pour
développer l'aide aux malades avec
soutien physique et psychologique 30%
pour la recherche exemple réduire les
effets secondaires très lourd des
thérapies enfin 20 % partent vers
l'afrique l'asie l'amérique latine pour
soigner les personnes contaminées des
programmes financés à partir de petits
dons en moyenne les français donnent 30
euros au sidaction
avec 30 euros il est tout à fait
possible de réaliser beaucoup de choses
prend l exemple au burundi on a un
programme de soutien pour des orphelins
du sida
on leur assure la scolarisation la prise
en charge médicale pour ceux qui sont
séropositifs de l'aide alimentaire et
avec 5 dont 2 30 euros dans l'année on
arrive à prendre en charge un enfant
intégralement l'année dernière 130 mille
personnes ont fait un geste
record à battre